ces espaces qui sont des espaces des
espaces à vivre plutôt que des espaces
de travail c'est la caractéristique de
cette structure de coworking travailler
comme si vous étiez à domicile installé
dans une maison du centre-ville de La
Queue-les-Yvelines le salon les chambres
ou les autres pièces de la Bâtie sont
été aménagés en espace de travail un
réaménagement jusqu'à l'ancienne piscine
une piscine couverte que nous avons
nous-même recouvert d'un parquet et qui
va être une salle de réunion pour
l'instant vous avez les chaises on aura
bien sûr les écrans qui pourront qui
pourront servir pour les réunions et on
va bientôt y installer une une table qui
arrivera incessamment sous peu
cofondateur de cet espace de coworking
Olivier Renault et ses équipes sont
installées ici depuis 2007 d'abord une
agence de communication ils se sont
réorientés en 2019 vers le coworking
cette histoire de coworking c'est un
petit peu la continuité de ce qu'on a
fait avec l'agence puisque c'était une
agence qui a été primée au 4 place Tower
que
les trois meilleurs entreprises où il
fait bon vivre en France l'esprit on a
voulu le faire perdurer on offrant aux
personnes qui qui travaillent chez eux
aujourd'hui
à l'espace où ils sont pas vraiment dans
des bureaux ils sont dans une maison on
est dans une maison de ville on est en
plein cœur de La Queue-les-Yvelines au
total 28 postes de travail sont
disponibles à des tarifs allant de 250 à
850 euros des espaces nomades fixes ou
des bureaux privés parmi les
utilisateurs installés il y a
l'entreprise Solier énergie une société
crée début 2022 spécialisé dans
l'installation de panneaux solaires nous
on a choisi de travailler au cowork à la
maison parce que ça nous permet d'avoir
une flexibilité de pou quand on
accueille des nouveaux collaborateurs
d'une part de pouvoir grandir sans avoir
la contrainte de voir changer de changer
de lieu aussi pour la convivialité qui
apporte un espace de coworking d'avoir
d'autres entreprises avec qui travailler
salariés d'entreprise entrepreneur ou
société entière peuvent s'installer dans
cet espace pour se sentir dans un
environnement comme à la maison